today we're unboxing the brand new 4th
gen ipad air
and it's pink it also has touch id on
the power button
the ipad air starts at 5.99 it has a
10.9 inch liquid retina display
a 14 bionic chip touch id on the power
button and has storage up to 256 gigs it
has support for apple pencil
magic keyboard and the smart keyboard
folio
here it is oh
my good look at this
beautiful pink color
it's like a beautiful perfect rose gold
oh my gosh take a look at this just just
look at this look at this okay look at
this
look at this power button let's turn it
on and set it up
there it is apple apple logo oh you're
beautiful you're beautiful you're
beautiful
i'm gonna place you right there with
your new friends what else is in this
box
ipad air instructional
no two apple stickers got the usbc
20 watt charger usb c cable have you
guys seen this before that focus is so
fast
i'm losing my mind it's so great wow
i just want to keep looking at the back
of it this is so pretty so the new ipad
air does come in five different colors
it comes in a space gray a silver a pink
a green and a sky blue did i
show you guys that i have the pink one
i'm just not sure if you
if you guys remember that this is i have
the pink one if somebody asked you guys
what my favorite color is
i mean i would give you just one guess i
wonder if you could figure it out okay
here we are use your fingerprint in
place of a passcode or apple id
for your purchases okay we're setting
this up right now
man do i wish this was on the new iphone
this is hope for the future
add another one if i'm holding the ipad
like this then i probably would want my
thumb
i never thought that registering my
fingerprint would be so riveting
oh my gosh okay added create a passcode
look how freaking beautiful this is
the ipad air does support the apple
pencil so let's open this up as well
and then we also have some really fun
accessories we have the ipad
smartfolio case and the magic keyboard
touch id unlocked pencil charging i'm so
happy you want me to try scribble okay
scribble is one of my favorite features
in the latest edition in ipad os so i'm
going to give it a little try here
hello i am
writing okay
so there we go now let's go into delete
so to delete a word you just
scratch it out and if you want to select
a word you just draw a line
or circle it so you can tap and hold in
the middle of the sentence to insert any
new words
so try inserting a
really new word to the sentence
okay oh god i'm just deleting everything
join characters separate words by
drawing a vertical line before
or after any character look at this
so if you're using your ipad and you
want to take a screenshot and then mark
up that screenshot you just go
to the bottom corner this will
automatically take a screenshot
and then this will let you start marking
this up
hello it feels just like magic
another cool feature is if you're at the
lock screen and you turn it on and you
press your apple pencil to the lock
screen
this will instantly bring up a blank
note so you can take a very quick note
an instant note instant
note okay now let's open up these
accessories this is the ipad smartfolio
and these come in all of the new colors
to match the ipad this was not planned
but i think i matched the cover i mean i
could not have picked
a more perfect matching shirt if i tried
whoa whoa i love this color so much
okay look how nice this looks
i'm ready for
doing ipad things look at me ready
ready who's ready me so that's the smart
folio
it's really nice and light so i feel
like this is a nice little addition
if you're just kind of slipping this
into your bag or something like that so
that you can protect your ipad both
sides
looks great so happy so let's open up
the ipad magic keyboard this is my
favorite thing ever i did a pretty
in-depth review of this i'll put links
in the description if you want to check
that out and also a follow-up video
where you guys ask me questions about it
and i answer them so i'm not going to be
going too in depth about this thing but
just let me tell you this thing's
amazing the best thing about this is it
has pass-through charging so you don't
have to plug it in
to the actual ipad there is a little
usbc port right on the side that will
let you charge it
look how small this is wow
nice quality very nice type
and over here this is the usbc port that
i was mentioning this allows for
pass-through charging so you can plug
your usb-c
right into here and this will allow your
ipad to charge without having to plug
your ipad in directly let's put you in
your new home
oh wow this is
really really nice so i have been using
the 12.9 inch ipad pro
which is a much much larger display
and a much larger magic keyboard case
this is actually the first time that i'm
seeing
this smaller version of the magic
keyboard it's
very very nice because this
this is huge look at this size
difference
the camera cutout is made for the ipad
pro but it still fits and it works with
this
so that is great news for anybody who's
interested in checking out one of these
magic keyboards
i also like this does have a backlit
keyboard which is really nice and you
can tell like the space bar looks a
little bit smaller the return
key is a little smaller shift keys so
they were able to pretty much still get
the same full size keyboard with just
making some of the keys a little bit
more compact this is definitely
something that i'm very excited about
my babies justine why are you gonna have
kids i've got two right here so i've
been wanting to test out this app this
is the dj app i haven't tried it yet so
we're about ready to go through the
tutorial here to learn
how to be a dj this is really cool
because this is going to be taking
advantage of the a14 bionic chip which
is incredibly fast
tap here to play deck 1.
oh my gosh
[Music]
yes it's going well this is going really
well
[Applause]
i mean this is kind of crazy like i'm
real time
getting rid of drums getting rid of
vocals
[Music]
right this is pretty
look at cool
hey dylan francis you see this skill
this is really fun and the fact that you
can be doing all of this real time and
live like completely just taking all of
these songs removing vocals removing
drum tracks
and basically becoming a dj right here
on your ipad
i think that i might need a little
practice though so
stay tuned maybe i'll do a live show on
twitch
what else do we have here what's this
flower oh this was originally really
some playstation
actually i remember this it's really
cool
go be free be free
this is so relaxing
[Music]
okay so that's running amazing
pixelmator photo ml super resolution
magically enlarged photos using
state-of-the-art machine learning
okay this is already a very large image
okay it's almost done it's 100 whoa
whoa i don't think they're gonna be able
to see it
it's definitely sharper
this was already a pretty sharp image so
it didn't have that much to i think we
need like a low res image
this is definitely a photo that could
use some touching up
what was i thinking about this makeup i
have
eyeshadow the same color eyeshadow all
over my entire eye
i didn't know any better okay let's do
the super resolution
really didn't help out this face mush
still same face
although yeah look at that
can you guys see that can you see that
made it a much
cleaner image around my face it sharpens
it but it also seems like it kind of
takes it and sort of
paints it in so it's not necessarily
just sharpening
see what kind of goodness look at that
okay this is a good demonstration look
at this
pixelated cleaned up
can you see it wow
let's check out these jeans
check out these jeans
cleaned up right here around the edges
nice little auto color
look at this look at this nice skin tone
i got a nice tan back
took out a lot of the blue let's try
call of duty mobile i'm not gonna use a
controller i'm just gonna
basically use the ipad and see how this
works
i'm getting my bearings i've never
played this on ipad before
[Applause]
hey hey come here you think you're gonna
hide from me you think you're gonna hide
from me
oh you guys are both here now okay well
guess what guess what uh
uh absolutely not this game instantly
makes me just
go crazy like look how good i'm doing
gravy
is it because everybody else is terrible
i just want to say that our team won
first time i've ever played on ipad
my kd was incredible look at this nine
kills zero deaths
six assists sign
me up for the pro leagues i already
talked a little bit about scribble but
it's so fun because you can do all sorts
of things so
we're going to go in here the first
thing i want to show you is when i
choose this this little a
pencil right here this will
automatically take the words that you're
writing
and turn them into text so this is
me writing
something i also like that i can use the
pencil and i can write some text i can
then select that text and then paste it
into a word document it'll take my
handwritten text
and turn it into actual text subscribe
to me please
tap it copy as text
and paste in
two pages you can also do smart shapes
so if you draw a shape and then hold
it'll automatically make you a circle
oops
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching i'm
looking forward to testing this out
further if there's anything you would
like to see me test or try on the new
ipad air please leave it in the comments
below and i will see you guys in the
next video
bye my precious it's funny i always say
like my presence i've never
even seen the movie means nothing to me
[Music]
you